قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه قرر
كيفيه الرد على الهجوم الذي تعرضت له
القوات الامريكيه في الاردن واضاف بايدن
ان حكومته لا تسعى الى حرب واسعه النطاق
في الشرق
الاوسط وكان موقع بوليتيكو عن نقل عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان الرئيس جو بايدن طلب
من مستشاريه
مجموعه خيارات للرد على مقتل ثلاثه
عسكريين امريكيين شمال شرق الاردن من
شانها ردع منفذي الهجمات على القوات
الامريكيه ولكن من دون مزيد من التصعيد في
المنطقه واوضح المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
خيارات الرد المطروحه لدى البنتاجون تشمل
ضربه عناصر عناصر ايرانيه في سوريا او
العراق او اصول بحر ايرانيه في مياه
الخليج وفي المقابل قالت مصادر ايرانيه
للجزيره ان الولايات المتحده ارسلت اكثر
من رساله لطهران خلال اليومين الماضيين
عبر اطراف ثالثه واوضحت المصادر ان رسائل
واشنطن اكدت انها لا تريد حربا مفتوحه
وحذرت من ان توسيع الحرب سيقابل بتحرك
امريكي واضح واضافت المصادر الايرانيه
للجزيره ان طهران رفضت تهديدات واشنطن
واعتبرت استهداف اراضيها خطا احمر سيقابل
برد مناسب كما اكدت ان رد طهران اشار الى
انها لا تريد حربا مع واشنطن لكنها ستواجه
بقوه ستواجه بقوه اي مغامره
امريكيه
وتنضم الينا من واشنطن مراسلتنا وجد وقفي
كما ينضم الينا من طهران مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز اهلا بكم ابدا
معك وجد اذا حديث كبير طويل عريض عن الرد
الامريكي على الهجوم الذي ادى الى مقتل
ثلاثه من الجنود الامريكيين ما ملامح الرد
ان اتضحت ايه معلومات عن
ذلك بالطبع الرئيس بايدن عندما سئل قبل
قليل اثناء توجهه الى ولايه فلوريدا
للقيام بنشاط انتخابي قال انه اتخذ قرار
كيفيه الرد على هذا الهجوم ولكن لم يشر
الى او لم يوضح كيف سيكون شكل الرد هناك
الكثير من
التسريبات تتحدث عن رد يكون على اكثر من
مرحله وفي اكثر من منطقه
اي الرئيس الامريكي قال انه يحمل ايران
مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم فقط من حيث انها الجهه
التي زودت منفذي الهجوم
بالاسلحه هذا يشير الى انه لن يكون هناك
اي ضربات داخل ايران كما تشير الكثير من
التحليلات شكل الرد اذا كما قلنا وحتى مما
المح اليه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن سوف يستهدف تلك الجماعات التي تقول
واشنطن انها مواليه لايران و ان ايران
تزودها
بالسلاح سوف تكون في اكثر من منطقه خديجه
طبعا هذه القرار عاده عندما يتخذ الرئيس
الامريكي قرارا للقيام بعمليه عسكريه فان
تنفيذه سوف يتم خلال الساعات ال
48 المقبله وفق تصريحات مسؤولين سابقين اي
اننا قد نتوقع بدء عمليه الرد على الهجوم
على القاعده الامريكيه في الاردن خلال
الساعات
ال8 المقبله وان كانت هناك لم توجه اي جهه
رسميه مثل هذه الفتره الزمنيه وهذه مجرد
تسريبات واستنادا ايضا الى عمليات
سابقه المهم الان هو ان الرئيس بايدن لا
يود ان يوسع اطار الحرب في الشرق الاوسط
لا يود اي تصعيد مع ايران سئل عما اذا
كانت الرد المقبل سوف يكون كافيا لردع تلك
الجماعات عن قيامها بايه هجمات نعلم بان
القوات الامريكيه تعرضت خلال الا الاشهر
الاربعه الماضيه الى اكثر من 160 هجوما
خديجه القوات الامريكيه الموجوده في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط لكن اي منها لم يوقع ايه
قتلى ضمن صفوف الجنود الامريكيين فقط هذا
الهجوم الذي تم الاخير هو الذي اوقع ثلاثه
قتلى ونحو 40 اصاب
في صفوف الجنود الامريكيين لذلك هناك توعد
من الرئيس الامريكي هناك جمهوريين يضغطون
باتجاه ان يكون الرد الامريكي موجها الى
الداخل الايراني كونه هي التي زودت هذه
الجماعات بالاسلحه ولكن بحسب الاستخبارات
الامريكيه والمعلومات الموجوده لديها حتى
اللحظه لا يوجد اي مؤشر بان ايران هي من
اعطت القرار لتنفيذ هذه الضربه خديجه شكرا
وجد و
عبد القادر اذا الهجوم يستدعي رد والرد
يقابل برد الرد الامريكي يقابل برد من
ايران ايران تهدد اذا هي الاخرى
بالرد يعني حقيقه خديجه هي دوامه في ما
بين الرد والرد المضاد والرد المضاد على
الرد المضاد هذا كلام صحيح حقيقه ولكن
يمكن ان نقول خديجه بان اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تفكر ب عمق
بحدود الردع الاستراتيجي الامريكي في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط فان ايران تفكر ايضا
بعمق بذات الصيغه ورسم خطوط حمراء امام
الرد الامريكي الخط الاحمر من المصادر
الايرانيه التي تحدثت للجزيره واضح وهو
الداخل الايراني في حال ذهبت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفق هذه المصادر الى
ضرب اهداف عسكريه او غير عسكريه داخل حدود
الجغرافيا الايرانيه فنحن ذاهبون الى
منطقه مختلفه تماما لا علاقه لها بالرد
والرد المضاد تقرا ايران ذلك بانه اعلان
عدوان مباشر حتى ان بعض المصادر تقول بانه
اعلان حرب من قبل امريكا على ايران يبدو
بان ايران في هذه المرحله تركز بشكل كبير
على هذه النقطه على الخط الاحمر بمعنى
الجغرافيا الايرانيه الداخليه هذه نقطه
مهمه في النقطه الثانيه تدرك ايران اهميه
ما تتحدث عن عنه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ضروره الرد امريكيا سواء في
صيغه المعادله الداخليه او حتى في الحضور
الامريكي في الاقليم ولكن تامل او ربما
تعتقد بان ذلك سيجري وفق حدود الاشتباك
السابق بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وايران لان ايران تقول بانه ما جرى في
الاردن لم يكن بقرار ايرانيا مباشرا وبان
ايران لا تعطي اوامر لهذه الجهات التي
تحسب على انها حلفاء لايران بشكل او باخر
وبان هذه الجهات وما تسميه محور المقاومه
يتحرك بشكل مستقل في الاقليم ولو انه كان
حليفا لايران ولو ان بعض التحركات تصب
لصالح ايران ولكن ايران لا تتعامل بمنطق
الاوامر بحسب هذه المصادر خديجا اخيرا
يمكن ان نقول بان ما تحدثت عنه المصادر
للجزيره يشي بان امريكا تتحرك ربما بسقف
تريد له ان يكون عقل ق لانيا ويشي ايضا
بان ايران تتحرك تحت ذات السقف ولو اننا
سمعنا كلاما ربما عاليا في مثل هذه
المرحله ولكن الجميع يدرك في ايران
والمنطقه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان
انزلاق مباشر بين طهران وواشنطن في هذه
المرحله باتجاه دوامه الرد والرد المضاد
هذا يعني بالضروره الوصول الى مرحله ربما
يكون العوده فيها الى الوراء شبه مستحيل
لذلك نسمع من قبل ايران كلاما واضحا بان
يجب على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تدرك بان الحل الاساس بالمعنى الاقليمي
موجود في غزه وليس فتح معارك تسميها ايران
معارك اقليميه وتوتر اقليمي في غنى عنه
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك
لكل دول الاقليم شكرا جزيلا لك عبد القادر
فايز مدير مكتبنا في طهران ول وجد وقفي
ايضا في واشنطن شكرا
لكما